well welcome welcome to your mom's house
and milk is vegan and milk is vegan
channel is vegan
Hamilton acrobatic part of that
acrobatic part of that no acrobatics
part of that acrobatics part ha ha
[Music]
acrobatics part acrobatics part
acrobatics part
acrobatics part of acrobatics RMC
acrobatic crushed a cock cock acrobatics
part
[Music]
I guess it's vegan then I guess you said
so yeah
acrobatic farts let's see who did that
it's by Chris Spence it's called
acrobatic farts by Chris Spence oh thank
you Chris oh thanks
good job jeans good job great jeans I
didn't tell you this yet but I am
editing my special and I went into the
office today to do it yeah and there's
this really cute like 20-something year
old girl who works the reception desk
what's her situation like well I didn't
I didn't look at them oh then no one
hear the rest of it she's really sweet
and every time I come in there you know
she's got like cool pink hair like she's
a cool younger girl she's not like a
dipshit basically right and she's not
overly enthusiastic or like she's she's
smart you can tell yeah so she always
takes my ID and checks me in and as I
was checking in today like a dad came in
and he was signing in and then another
dad came in behind her and was like
April don't let him in I don't I don't
know this guy is hateful don't let them
in don't let em in April April don't
want any kept repeating it and she kept
ignoring him yeah as did the guy who was
signing in because we were like we get
the joke dad and I I felt so bad for her
cuz I could see it she just like this
ass yeah I love it
yeah good joke yeah and you know she
hears it Legos jokes oh my got a little
bob jokes yeah I mean poor April's
probably heard that a thousand no no
this is yeah hey hey good you see this
guy check him out all right all right
and she's she but the best part about
her oh my gosh I love blood jokes the
best part is that she didn't even feign
that it was funny what she's so broken
by it that she was like yeah I get it
mark or whatever it was like right well
to the 300th day that you've done this
yeah but that is the plight of being an
attractive young female is that dad
boners are always cracking jokes and
trying to get your
in chin and get you to laugh at them
because their wives hate their guts
probably like your children are over
them so they that's why they always like
to flirt with waitresses and young you
know what it is I think it is that I
think it is it's not about it's about
attention yeah - right attention because
their wives are like and shutting it
down
yep their wives are in menopause so
anyone's eyes who light up at anything
yet becomes exciting to them no no eyes
light up at home nobody finds them funny
at home right their kids are old enough
to know that their sense of humor
wouldn't one person offices like I like
mark you know like that's funny and he's
like this is great and the feeling is
great yeah poor mark no attention like
nobody cares about him anymore it's
funny because we've been we spent the
weekend together the week together
you've been home it's been great and we
went on an overnight trip a way out so
where we save it we went on overnight
and we got to see like dad's swimming
and mom's walking around and we noticed
there we were in the lobby and there was
this poor son of a bitch wearing a
really baggy suit and then in white move
out right and then Hance first of all
was a it wasn't a suit was it was just
trousers and yeah and a sports coat that
but they didn't go together
oh yeah that's okay then you know help
each other in sure there was no you know
unison the colors didn't go together and
they were too short you had high waters
on so they were high up and we we were
walking towards yeah yeah and what did I
say you go nobody loves him yeah he has
no love nobody nobody loves him I even
asked him under my I didn't invite him
here I go - nobody loved you because
knowing if somebody loved Deneb you like
we were all this right well that's the
life's job you got to check your spouse
even it's a husband's job to check the
lady yeah so that you don't go out into
the world looking like a dipshit he
looked like a real dummy yeah
it wasn't just you know this isn't just
fashion commentary he looked
broken yeah well just dorky like I'm not
saying that I'm a fashion he said by any
stretch but there are certain rules to
the game like you know the white dad
sneakers and high water is definitely
not a good look not a good look and we
were driving in the car and we saw a
lady who totally shut it down crossing
the street and she was wearing what
looks like those peva kind of
Birkenstock sandals with no socks you
know talking out like they're really
utility sandal the Denver sandal the
Denver sandal and then a pair of cargo
shorts and then like really functional
looking tank top as well with all beige
and short short hair it does you know
there's a thing you always say this but
and I think people will probably like oh
my god are you guys serious about this
but I think it's true that you don't see
as much of that in Europe I feel like oh
absolutely not growing up my mother and
my stepmother kept their shit on fleek
like so what if you had the baby
yesterday like you're asking to have
your manicure done your makeups going to
be on you're going to be wearing a nice
dress and you're going to be back down
to size six bitch yeah like in Europe it
is I mean I think it is unheard about we
were at the beach today with LJ and I
see two little boys playing and the
mother and father just hanging back
there's no coolers there's no
overwhelming toys umbrella the mother
looks skinny good shape yeah and I what
I say to you you said well yeah I
remember when we saw some animal and you
said I promise on that words I'll never
look like that animal for you but I said
those aren't Americans oh yeah I go this
definitely that's right you did you did
Spock yeah I'm not American anyway there
wasn't really a dead giveaway to that
being true but then you talk to them and
you were right yeah the lady I talk
they're from the Ukraine yeah I knew it
I knew it because you look great no
you're not all panic that your kids are
jumping off the rocks you know they're
they were in a million toys and you know
Americans love to bring the whole
fucking barbecue grill to the beach in
the fucking tent and 99 Americans are
saying well I mean like I don't know I'm
not sure but I do know that growing up
my mother kept her shit tight like she
still look good and she dressed like a
woman
and same with my stepmother dressed like
a woman just like a woman not like as
their right and I do feel like that is
an American woman thing that for some
reason menopausal age and you shut up
shut the fuck down to the hormone shift
I get it I totally get the it's hard
especially we have a baby I don't feel
pretty anymore
well I did to further that point I think
the men in the in those cultures also
keep it more together yeah because you
see less dad who's just like completely
let it go yeah now that it doesn't exist
obviously you know soldiers but you see
less of it you see less you see more
effort put into self maintenance yes
even basic fashions you know I remember
in my semester abroad when I lives with
this old lady in an all-night in Madrid
her son was 20 years older than me we
come visit that dude always look you
know presentable he always go to sharp
and he goes he told me he goes you know
how we know when an American into
walking down the street
no no how he goes you this thank you
that's right look at me right now
wherever you I was oh yeah
he's like D shirts with a big stupid
things on them yeah and George starts
yeah like agreed I think that's how we
know that Americans because we look like
kids
yeah okay thanks man now the flip side
is that we've earned the right to look
like shit cuz we're number one you know
saying that is though like a result of
that it is it's like you know what on
the other hand that's our culture we
don't go fuck fuck you this is my house
this is what I do is my Barcalounger
fuck you and I respect that too so I'm
on both sides of the fence here I think
it's I think it's a fair thing to feel
both ways actually yeah because there's
just times where you feel like hey can
we just fucking keep it together a
little more and then there's times where
you go fuck it okay alright
I'm just going to target I'm looking
like shit today you know I want my house
slippers out a few times you know in the
first year of the MLS of life I think
it's going to do it's kind of a boss
move I mean you see a lot
in LA where the somebody pulls up in
$100,000 car but they were wearing
t-shirts and shorts and slippers that is
like a very I don't know I see that as
an American thing right absolutely
this is a really exploit like I'm not
going to go out of my way to match that
definitely and a specifically West Coast
thing you have West Coast millionaires
that look like hobos a lot right a lot
yeah you look at I mean yes some of the
most especially in show business like
they look like fucking douche bags
ya know in restaurant like that is he
runs fuck that studio and like that guy
he looks like shit I looks like he's
falling apart and but I think just
generally I think I don't know why but
especially mothers in America I think
there's this thing of like you have
children and now you're totally
desexualized like you're just an asexual
exist you got to shut it down
and it's that it is sad just because I
feel like European women there's still a
sexuality there after you have children
and shouldn't stop right you from
fucking like yeah I silly by the way I'm
glad that this is one of your things
when your hangups right you're always
folks I'm like yeah stay fuckin thinking
that you're a woman well cuz you're
still a person after you have children I
don't know why having children makes you
or the culture allows you to just like
well I live kid now I gotta shut
everything down zygors RI why aren't you
still a sexual being you're still a
person give you a kid yeah you're just
raising a child that's the thing it's a
it's a mental shift they're saying I
have a kid
therefore I have to give fully to this
kid and all those other aspects of who I
was or am I have to close up but you
know you don't have to one doesn't
exclude the other right you can have a
we can have many identities yeah
mommy is just but I think to that's the
big mommy obsession in this country to
that moms have to be perfect and yeah be
totally devoted 100% all the time it's a
lot of pressure and if you don't then
you're bad yeah but I suck you're bad
moms because you licked at balls I don't
know about that part I don't know that
we're
what's uh-oh we have done a proper show
open but I want you to talk about my
future when we got it we got it
alright let's get this show started
officially official official here we go
but I want to get the message out there
it's okay form in the park as I'm
fighting for women's rights
no like artemus you embarrass me they
don't want us bed in a guys laughing
like I'm the type of guy you know I
don't mind like I'm into that stuff so
I'm trying to get guys like me that's to
join this business because I think we
can prove a change the world is like
women part of their thing who is Randi
don't bring anyone love into this
[Music]
I don't just fucking lunatic is I didn't
know there was a problem with women Bob
Smith sits around Union Square in New
York City filming all from the Karen oh
okay so he'd know Bob is one that's
filming the people so he has millions of
these duty films in the videos named
Roman he smells woman's farts to fight
for women's rights by the way I think
the tie in there that I was thinking was
that part of shutting it down what is a
result of feminism in other words I
think for probably many years it was so
unacceptable to shut it down that part
of like a backlash count backlash was
I'm going to shut down I'm not doing
that for you trim you know so yeah I do
think that there's it and people thank
God people like like Roman are keeping
women's rights you know on the table how
selfless of him to sniff women's asses
in public so they feel like I love my
favorite thing is want to do who's just
who's just trying to get a nut yeah
changes the narrative to that it's a
bigger thing go crash one of my favorite
moves of dudes and only men are capable
of spinning that type of non to get laid
yeah like dude you just like farts yeah
because it makes your dick hard you
don't feel like I want to change the
world and right the best is the Guru the
guy who's like the twin goddess
activation oh yeah horse shit alright
guys just if I could finish bank less
aside and the rub rub guy I mean he's
just a guide like the jerk is cocking
all day everyone
my hand is much did you get
but I think one time a girl his
assignment and a fart smeller that he's
holding in Union Square which is a dad
joke - of the guy's a real fart smeller
I mean smart feller here no no no I've
heard that one but that's good yeah
they're not actually farting though
they're just putting their button
yourself - I could just like to
establish a motion I told Sam foreign
support yeah a lot of them are really
far - a lot of them are really farting
cool man
yeah he just perv it likes to sniff girl
done and don't let him but I mean that's
it man you have to be like message out
there
you're not funny what a crusader but I'm
an ancient I know why I'm crying against
guys like me that's the joy of business
I know why because - the reason that
white women
fart in their favor the reason that he
says that is because it's led to it
happening so many times another word
he's he's asked women kind of fart my
face and a lot of you know sometimes
it's happened sometimes not but when he
changes the narrative to impact man I'm
in penguin was right I think it's
ridiculous then every once in a while
somebody's like okay like he hoses them
into that so now it's automated in his
head like that's what I got to say right
it's positive spin on a very negative
weird thing which I mean I congratulate
him for finding that but it is nonsense
that Sweeney's right
really that's weird it is right things
getting and Hollywood tri-state
make us more like like em like get rid
of civilization civilization the
capitalism in the pound like we are
party charges in stock market return the
second animal is we gotta worry about so
this episode we share everything and we
have fun with all these different like
Asian kappa yeah antique nods anti
capital right now is he's really going
out there it's got a bigger scope really
going to change why don't you give him
some credit for house alright
that's very close-minded me to to see it
that way do you think he has a
girlfriend like what's the life choice
what's his personal life what I almost
so curious about these lunatics like
what do you think is happening this guy
probably could have a much more
fulfilling life but he wasn't so hung up
on those farts all the time I think it's
probably I think it's a big distraction
for him and probably a lot of his
thoughts and then days are just in you
know when his parents are like what'd
you do this weekend he has to come up
with a whole other story because he's
like I spent Friday planning this thing
and then Saturday I got to the park at 8
a.m. and I redid my sign it wasn't right
and then and then I spent about six
hours so you're saying that it kind of
an obsessive thing with him I think I've
taken over his life at this annoying
yeah I think you're right I think this
guy should just hire someone to I think
so it he probably gets so much more done
if he would just like find a woman if
it's not a woman that he could date then
just be like hey do you think you could
spend like a few hours of farting and
like I'll pay you
yeah I mean then he doesn't have money
that's the problem yeah he doesn't have
money he doesn't have a job he's got all
the time of devote so the fart smelling
thing is a lot to movement he's creating
a movement babe but I think if he would
get a job and just hire his fart lady
see that would be better you get more
done in life you know it is more
productive I got to get some things done
dude well look there's a lot of lady
that liked like they like to fart later
we found their videos wide eject well
actually in this thing maybe because it
looked old
well the most kind of old I would think
that with the right amount of ads just
computer you know website ad like going
on meet people that he could especially
like some fetish connect them yeah yeah
he could probably find someone I mean do
you like the far yeah I like smell them
sure he seemed nice enough that I'm sure
somebody would like him you know
yeah he's somebody's type you could have
you could have dinner with that guy he
was a and I know I'm not saying you yeah
I'm saying that like he's not so weird
that you go like that guys just fucking
straight-up psycho it is obsession
though he's placing all of his eggs in
the fart basket emotionally you know
speaking of that you know what hasn't
happened in a while we haven't gotten
the main farter alright give top dog a
call I'd love it top dog hey buddy top
dog hey buddy
top dog you need to write down top dog
hey yeah so let's see here
yeah so on our trip on our overnight
mommy trip we just took we heard a brand
new dad joke from Radio that I did some
radio it was like on I called in to like
choppy chopper and the road dog yeah
yeah my friend I love by the way that my
called in the radio though sometimes
right before Dotel use in the room so
they'll be like hey it's a man in mic
just so you know you're on the phone or
thing like okay
and this time they were like hey it's a
it's a gym the Ranger and Laura like
uh-huh sure
like it's a carrier I don't know these
people are but I mean also just that
you're going to be like can I talk to
the Ranger right right right yeah I mean
you're going to talk to hound dog in the
blood game really I'm not going to ask
for hound dog I do not in yes anyways
we're talking about you yeah and I got
like I realized I just had a serious
tone I was like you know we've been
together and blah blah and then I can
tell the digit they're just kind of
waiting like this serious and then I go
but you've got a couple of you know big
old hangars on her and that's grand
they're like oh that's awesome man
oh yeah shy ghosts got two big floppers
on her he's like I love this guy and
he's Laura here she's got a couple of
state troopers on her which I actually
think is very funny about those funny
groupers I've never heard that before
pretty great that is such a great new
dad joke
I think that's rich funny we have to run
by stopped of course we had to get his
tab improve on it state a couple of
state troopers what stupid
actually tell us we found that somebody
said it yeah he calls his wife stead
state triage a couple of glow dad yes
hey buddy how you doing yeah it's been a
while yeah how long has been well I'm
doing good you know just working half to
eight is nice that's nice you know
okay it is you know one of my buddies
has a funny reference I don't know if
you've heard this before but he calls
his wife's boobs
state troopers called her what he calls
her boobs
state troopers oh my god
can't believe oh that what I call a
loving comment yeah good state and
pretty funny I don't play trooper women
you know they got to where they don't
make bulletproof vest remember bucks
do they not oh well what do they didn't
know of I mean are you well nervous in
the bulletproof vest market I asked one
of my I asked one of my you know my
secretary is uh oh thanks a cop yeah
okay and rested they have a special
model for women and she says I don't
think so oh all right very well Rick I
wait accurate yeah so there's been a lot
of excitement anticipation about what's
going to happen with fart mistress calm
the website that I bought and and and
whether or not mom is going to fart on
it and you know
at first I was going to try to raise
money but now I think what I'm going to
do is just pay her myself but she was
saying that she felt like a prostitute
but I mean she don't to get naked or
anything you just fart what's the big
deal you know I really don't understand
I mean the other day I did I I tell you
about that that shit I did the other day
oh god no no all right so I'm on a I'm
on a road trip up there see and Jane and
we're always happens when you go on a
road trip is to get up in the morning
you hit the road and I'm on the highway
yeah and if I do that you know my 815
bombs away
time is doesn't happen so I went a whole
day without a single shit Oh No yeah
that's really bad well I knew it was
going to happen the next day I know it's
going to be ugly
so woke up you know I'm home back to my
normal routine kind of did a kind of a
you know kind of smaller one probably
because I don't know we couldn't win
that big and then drive into the heat
where we live and all of a sudden I feel
it coming and I know that feeling I said
oh my god am I going to make it so you
were on your way in or out on the way
into the subdivision okay yeah so you
know heading down there and then you
know you know that feeling when you have
to go you have to kind of squeeze your
cheeks together you have to stretch your
legs out yeah how far are you from the
house as you're feeling this oh I'm you
know quarter mile okay I make the
left-hand turn down I straight pull in
the driveway but then I got to get out
of the car you know that I got to keep
my teeth together as I'm getting out of
the car and the whole idea is you know
to try to run in there and hand make
that right turn and when I made that
right turn you know some of it just
slipped out what and why
some of the shit King came out and when
I got down the toilet oh yeah you know
it was really messy you know I mean I
had a head from in fact it was so messy
that I had to wipe I don't normally do
this but I had some of my left cheek I
had to you know wipe my left cheek with
my left hand I mean you know yeah that's
it especially I need unorthodox it feels
different right to use your other thing
well it does it's very unorthodox and
then then I look down at my underwear
and I can see some shit basically I had
a tootin you know niblets in my
underwear and then I left inside my
trousers and some of it fell into inside
my trousers so do you throw that stuff
away what do you do with that oh no I
just rip it rip it off in the laundry we
just rented often definitely so Canada
yeah that's go why would you why
wouldn't you just throw the underwear
out well why so it's perfectly good
underwear 19 I mean or it's not the
cover - because it's got it listen
listen I I know a lot about you know
sunset and your pants kind of stuff and
thanks a lot more that to run a good
pair of underwear what is it I mean what
would it take to ruin a good pair of
underwear
I'll say one the elastic gets worn out
become een so if you had like a cool if
you got a full shit in your pants you
still keep them yeah I mean I died what
I do is to take the shit put it in the
toilet and uh read the rest of it in
there and a lot guys listening looking
then it's in that beat and then you know
you just recycle listen tell me all
these nasty he'll throw go down to where
away then but it's not any not good
anymore that's the whole point
well it is good once once you put in
washing machine and hot water and soap
it comes out nice and white or blue
whatever color - what I know and another
episode no you should just try I tell
you what I would
the issue here really for me was I have
to when I really got to go I got to work
on making those turns into the bathroom
are you going to work on that yeah
because I made that turn and of course
it means you put your legs and when you
make that turn
that's one my ways the lawsuit I'm what
turn are you talking about though going
from in the house to the bathroom so
through the laundry room
yeah the laundry room then I gotta turn
rights closest bathroom you know is a
guest bathroom you jump in the shower
after that oh yeah of course yeah after
yeah after yeah yeah I had to it was
such a mess I had jump in the shower and
[Music]
clean hey oh my god what's up with the
I'm just changing the topic because I'm
about to puke in my mouth but what do
you are you into those new bra new bras
mom God are you still digging those or
you not I mean you're not liking those
anymore well I'm a lace man okay yeah I
was like it I always like to see through
you know give a little you know see you
through there see that nipples and other
things I'm always been a lace guy and
you know these functional lift bras with
I've never been my my favorites but yeah
I'm not going to tell her that is she
wearing them on it what is she wearing
now the functional ones oh yes you she's
off like sonar yeah well why don't you
just get her some lace ones yeah just
chill where he is but she doesn't is she
did but she likes to functional um yeah
you know so I was telling uh I was
telling Christina fitted about this girl
I went out with in college once who she
had such a full bush that it looked like
she had a pair of balls when she when
she had her panties on it was like too
much well you know my generation it was
all about the bush okay oh it I mean my
generation the girls never shaved okay
just just to do that and you would
classify women by nationality whether
they had big Bush or low Bush oh really
oh yeah
yes or basically your Italians the
Greeks yeah you know Jewish that black
white bushes or Scandinavians you're you
know right though Asians the head you
know very little right and with and and
and the Irish to death the English you
never know what you were going to get
with that I mean it was all over the map
okay but the big ones right there the
big the big black bushes were the you
know that kind of lower European
Mediterranean right in the yet well
that's what this girl was she was
Portuguese yeah yeah I can imagine
I mean I saw those panties and I go I'm
about to hook up with a guy right now
well I'll tell you some of those girls
in those days they did partial shades
because you know they would it would
almost be like a reverse triangle you
know would counter the hair would kind
of go up towards enables the girls would
would shave themself partially like from
below the navel because it would yeah we
grow up so high oh yeah you couldn't
wear a bikini otherwise oh I see yeah
yeah that's very common in our
generation yeah yeah this girl had a lot
of hair a small penis but a lot of hair
she had a small penis but a lot of hair
that's good that's good yeah I'm so
thrilled yeah yeah thank you
yeah but I haven't had an accident like
that time you in a long time ah I feel
like I feel like it's happened a few
times in the last year though I feel
like it's not that that's all that's all
do you know it's all due to when I
travel on the car what happens is you
know when you get up you're not in your
routine you eat differently in the
morning yeah coffee you know you're on
the road and then for some reason it
just stays there in your rectum or I
know I have a lot of travel day problems
you know travel day affects
I don't know how you do it quite frankly
I mean you know I don't know I'm getting
I'm getting my teeth whitened the week
after next
give me to set you guys left when you're
out here your mother would want me to
get my teeth white are you opposed to
that now I'm not I just want it to be so
white but it makes me look like you know
some kind of Christmas decoration oh I
hope it does I'm going to take that's
going to be my gift see if you come out
in the next few months
yeah well we're working on that
Thanksgiving thing okay so is that all
right that'd be great
all right look I got a run I love you
I've calculated everybody okay pretty
much amazing I didn't know about the
lacy bra that he loves you animal all
right
and we would classify them this is okay
that is so gross how does it feel to
know your dad's sexuality and his sexual
preference and more than I need more
than I do you feel like you want to
marry your dad uh-huh no so gross right
yeah how come it's never okay to know
your parents sexual stuff even when
you're like a 40 year old grown-ass man
I don't know never want to know when I
hear about it what gives your dad a hard
on know any like thing he gets more
comfortable with it with age because
we'll be hanging out and be like Ben
she's gonna she'd take Karia
all right in the sack get her over there
like uh yeah that she would be a couple
of state troopers okay thank you
all right we gotta remind him about that
when he's out here so that he starts
saying it more I feel like he could
really adapt that he would love to
introduce that to his friend that's why
I'm saying you just need some reminders
we need to drill him on it and then
whole yeah he'll take it back to four
you know we made love recently and it
was great but I was thinking there's
always room to improve you know so we're
going to talk about one of the scariest
part of
initial dating experience and that's the
first kiss we're going to talk a little
bit about the first kiss and then we're
going to talk a little bit about some
advanced kissing this real this is real
this is real one of the things it's
really cool about kissing we always have
learned to kiss when we're both giving
and receiving at the same time but
actually an amazing way to kiss is just
to give or just to receipt snowboy
that's true what do you think it happens
back to Ana
let's go Royal oddly each is going to
receive my kiss just start there
[Music]
I hate watching people kiss she's not
kissing back so she's appealing all my
energy that we talked about in the touch
exercise and the sensation of softness
my lips against hers I was looking for
oh he looked like such a fucking dad
total boner do you but there's not
what's called being a bad kisser when
you're just limp and you don't respond
well they're advanced so maybe not their
intimacy expert Sofia I was making out
with her golf coach yeah tee superlame
dude
well he's not cool at night or Sheba
like he's super boner II like she's not
even you not even trying gave up I know
he just seemed like such a fucking
manager of the you know the glug the
sunglasses shop yeah he's such a ford
corners dude all right so little ones
you can do you have a whole playground
around this you have the outer part of
the lips you have minutes this is real
you have upper lip lower lip which feels
entirely different to absolutely how you
know that you fucking nerd yeah dorks
you can use your lipstick ink you can
use one enough throw up your tongue to
kissing you can do all this just on the
outer lips before we go inside you can
drive you slick you're better there we
go
I gotta say I get ponytail guy right
here
how is that good I got a comfortable
watching that scene in delians when they
and Michaud perceived real fucking oh
yeah no time loves to do that by the way
Jesus
Showtime will always open on
uncomfortable sexy yeah but that guy the
star of billions has a weird mouth he
does you and I have taught he was oh he
played agent Brody Brody Steven Steven
Brody Stevens even Brody Stevens from
homeland he played the red-haired guy
that Claire Danes you know probably
where but his mouth is just so hard a
name for that to get over it I called
Bert mouth or something where they have
like the shape of the teeth is weird
Bert way out yeah you know who else has
a mouth like that Bill Walton you know
that it is and of course you don't look
at this you have so much disdain for my
lack of sports knowledge you know no but
I don't care about sports why would I
know this hey such a dork he didn't get
laid at all who's doing that intimacy
expert let's see here why would you pay
money for these two dorks to do aw look
at those teeth but see how the chompers
are unusually large the shape the shape
is kind of similar yeah not good oh my
god yeah I'm saying his lips agent Brody
Stephens lips is weird uh-huh God the
teeth are all wrong and they're all fake
so he should have had them done smaller
yeah
but he's always had that I mean that's
the shape of his mouth you know he has
that what's that guy's name they have
the same mouth no yeah it's similar but
his lips are not that where the teeth
start to go back is the sooner so in
other words the mouse goes is more than
the teeth are more narrow than wide okay
look up Bert agent Brody agent okay like
a billions yeah just Google billions of
the star and so people know we're
talking about but his lips are weird I'm
just saying the shape of his without his
mouth open even I don't the lips to
really put me off yeah plus he's a
red-haired guy it's not my it's not my
lane Damian Lewis
not an actor yeah he's a great actor
he's like I think New Zealander Nike or
Bray or whatever he not no or Australian
her mom's Chilean he does the American
accent flawlessly
he's English English you can't even tell
that guy is English yeah no yeah he and
my wife were fucking in their pool which
by the way I don't know who has sex in a
pool because all the water goes up your
vision and it's so uncomfortable
it's bullshit yeah his mouth looks super
weird but it looks weirder when it's
closed his lips hurt yeah see see the
shape of it like he's such a great actor
you know his mouth always bothered me in
homeland just probably bothered him a
lot too
yeah but he's like he's gotten I mean
for having a weird mouth yeah he's a
really confident weird mouth guy yeah
see how you're talking about they go
back yeah yeah where as opposed to wide
right yeah so that and that's what Bill
Walton is saying they got it like us
it's like a smiley shape or something
I'm teeth yeah so weird huh yeah it's
like it's a that's what it is yeah no I
know those are but the teeth out they
also went way too big on those veneers
man got it careful with those veneers
those are huge
they're donkey teeth yeah by the way
what if we get my dad to get really
really really whitey okay and veneers do
like super white dog yeah so fucking
hard well I'm just thinking one last
time your dad went to the dentist normal
oh yeah I know we what we could ask that
it's been a while it has been a while
your sisters are always so mean to him
about his breath towards like God your
breath and they shot like gum in his
mouth on her oh yeah your dad's got the
worst dad mouth to get so little dad
mouth yeah he's got total total fucking
bad mouth isn't that the dad just don't
brush their teeth at all is that what
happens or just being old like a parent
so there's a lot a lot of things you can
do you have a whole
you have a outer part of the lips you
have your inner part of the lips you
have opposition or lip which feel
entirely different you at throw up the
pinkie is rejected you can use one
little really Stephanie we're doing is
we're kissing with our eyes open yeah no
that can you obtain it and there's a
connection of our hearts there's the
connection of our lips
there's the connection of our eye here's
why that's a bull can we just dance
kissing with your eyes open is also how
someone who has never kissed before that
right
then there's right there trying to say
this is advanced if you if you have to
eighth graders makeout they're going to
go right mm-hmm
and one of them's going to go close your
fucking eyes weird
basically what they're giving you is
like rookie kissing move and they're
saying that it's advanced it's not
advanced a little bit this is fucking
your eyes like one of the other times
integrated you and your kissing is using
your breath and others okay well Wayne
that can happen and you can actually
even middle to what
is merely to watch people do
oh my god someone did that to me I would
vomit if someone and that's the thing is
that I would laugh yeah it's
intentionally trying it's trying hard to
be sexy like I was watching the show
gypsy on Netflix two guys two guys again
she's done with him yet right it's not
about them though John you know and
Naomi Watts is making out with his girl
this younger girl and she goes I want
you to dance for me and the girl does it
and it's so corny and we were just there
making fun of it last night I was like
Tom away dance for me like who does that
like who can do it with a serious face
people that aren't assholes that's the
thing is we're too jaded to do that
right yes of course I feel like that
would be taking myself way too seriously
the by the way I told you about the
tongue League kisser yeah they're
telling you to do that these dorks that
was terrible I thought that was some
juvenile shit there's like a woman I
went out with a few times and every time
like even if you were like okay so I'll
see you later
you gave a kiss she picked onion no yeah
waiting no you mean she would lead with
her tongue right she wasn't like which
they're telling you to do like yeah you
would just I mean it's for us like what
you would expect to be just a not a
make-out kiss just a peck goodbye act
but good buyer or good I'd pick you up
like good to see you you feel the tongue
come into your mouth and I was like I
can't get over this ain't dealing
condition I remember telling people I
worked with I was like I don't think I
can get over this because I don't know
how to bring it up yeah how do you bring
that up this and it wasn't at one time
this was oh it was like an accident like
I know we went out probably four or five
times and every time she gave you hello
and goodbye kiss every time every single
kiss had done every single one so do you
think that she just had it out there you
know how parakeets like they always have
their tongue kind of it was just always
out I don't know I think that she my
interpretation was she thought this is
super sexy oh it's just training me and
an expert intimacy
person not a novice like us and I was
more like you don't mean you can pull
you and pull that in sometimes yeah I
mean imagine imagine if every kid the
tongue was going Indian I don't like it
like you watch it's too much time yes
I don't like method of having anxiety
about her kisses of course no of course
I don't even like mouth kissing friends
goodbye
yeah or merit hasn't my son I think it's
more with women I have had women friends
whereas definitely there's nothing there
sexually they're married or they're
there in relationships and they're happy
and they greet with mouth kisses I agree
yes I'm saying it is not women but with
men yes male friends and I'm like I want
and I kind of determine so guys will
lead with it yeah see I've never I mean
I've never stood they'd never done to me
I didn't know that men would lead with
yeah yeah it's like it's an LA thing
it's like a hipster it's like a cool la
person thing is really yeah if you're
cool you do a mouth kiss huh I don't do
I don't kiss these little melon yeah
that's like it's like a cool person good
to see you
now kiss yeah yeah I mean the last time
it felt to me like it was kind of a cool
but high society thing yeah that right
gray it was elite people that I that I
encountered doing that or and then it
always was so jarring to have to be like
well would you do like that I told you I
I had friends in high school who the
whole family kissed on the mouth the son
would kiss the dad's mouth the mother
would kiss the son's mouth the little
girl the sister would kiss the brother's
mouth the dad and the and the son would
kiss on the mouth okay like what and he
was like 17 years old by gay night good
bye guys are so everybody's mouth
kissing in the whole family it was a lot
super weird
I played them one time and I brought
this up on the show like many years ago
one time I was kissing my stepdad
goodbye and he turned his head just as I
was going
for his cheek and we and I kissed like
the corner of his mouth yeah like I've
been thinking about it for 20 years
yeah that's how long ago that you guys
say something no no no it was just like
no but you think about it like one time
I corner mouth kiss my stepdad gross
yeah that's gross I was making
uncomfortable mouth kiss your mom there
were you ever kiss your mom uh-huh
there's just like the geese it's just
like the game no no gross yeah no I
don't want mouth kisses not from the
family or strangers
I even our son I feel weird I feel like
that's not okay
mouth kissing I said I've seen that
people kiss their children like this
yeah and I know a lot of people do it to
small kids I think that it's not too
crazy what happened the boys like 12 or
you still mouth kissing your son
probably I'm not sure that's okay don't
get mommy kiss on the mouth what else
they have the intimacy experts these two
are the experts and that's how it's done
we saw how it moves back and forth and I
would pause and then Johanna would pause
I would pause and then you kill the
other person pause and you know that's
your cue to take leave and you need to
kiss the line dance with it and you can
play inside and outside slowly moving
your tongue or even using your teeth
just in a gentle way but you can do so
much and you can feel the energy it
would make me feel like a failure
to be at this oh my god some of you oh
my god okay would you rather would you
rather the other thing that's right now
come on you don't even listen okay would
you rather okay would you rather Burning
Man we go to Burning Man for two weeks
and you're two weeks
you're not shower you got the playa home
you got playa dust in your asshole in
your eyes and your beard
you're taking shits and porta-potties
it's 120 degrees during the day you know
me well there's there's a vagina eating
contest there's dirty hippies everywhere
or it's two weeks of the intimacy class
I think I would go to the end of the
intimacy I think you found my I can't do
Burning Man for two weeks two weeks what
if it's one week each what if I shorten
the time everything about Burning Man is
what I hate
so are Coachella this desert Coachella
energy would at least entertain me and
I'd be more entertained by the intimacy
class but this will be but the it's the
intimacy that makes me uncomfortable how
is that because then they'll be like Tom
and Christina you guys try in front of
everybody and then I be like oh my I
know but I would be laughing and I'd
like that there's air conditioning and
there's a bathroom all the hours it
really bothers me about those festivals
well The Burning Man in particular
because it's playa dust you're out on a
playa whatever no I did them some
fucking idiot that listens to our show
it message me about he's like when did
you become like like such a bitch about
crowds now always I'm like we talking
about yeah and also I never understand
when somebody's like upset about you not
liking something that they like yeah
it's like why the fuck do you think that
that's a logical point to bring up hey
man I like festivals how can you not
like festival I'm not you you dumb fuck
yeah I know he has to have everybody
agree with you why would that in the
world we all have to like the same
things
but they're obviously there are scores
of people who love Burning Man love
Coachella and many more who don't just
not for us yeah it's not my scene man
I'm a fucking adult I can't do that crap
somebody I'm going to dult message does
this is a pretty cool grown-ass woman I
don't sit in my own filth for a week
like an asshole no here we go look at
this yeah hold on email hey mommy's I
was talking to my wife about our weight
loss I completely forgot what inspired
me to change my life in the summer of
I weighed just over 500 pounds I was
always a big funny guy I love comedy one
night after work my wife and I decided
to watch Tom's special well as you know
you have a bit about how you shouldn't
have diarrhea every day and mommy Tina
offers a ride to the hospital this is
100% true by the way a bit is based on
reality you came out we were in Silver
Lake and you came out and I go do you
need to go to awesome align yards in the
business real life
that shit was the funniest thing I've
ever heard I remember thinking ha ha ha
only my oh my god that's totally true
that's me oh my god that is me it was
the only statement that actually broke
through my fat head and now I'm down 225
pounds Wow my wife joined me soon after
she has lost 125 pen well together we've
lost half a burnt Chrysler Wow
I mean it's true I'm a thank you your
comedy does a lot more than make people
laugh I have a capitated before and
after over a year but here's some proof
next time you're in Columbus come over
for some moose look at this is the early
so here he's over five bills
oh man Ares lost 225 pounds amazed
congratulations gene that is really
something man that is really some ain't
congratulations to you wow really great
I don't see is your name in here no so I
don't know who said this but you
obviously know who you are if you send
it and Wow
congratulate you as I'm speaking of
moose soup similar so my god people have
gone bananas
for Moo soup lady we can get into some
of that and we did it because you asked
us to a lot you asked us here to calm
down for moose soup shirt on sale go to
merge method calm slash Tom Segura and
you will see a the moose soup lady shirt
come down later vamoose oooh who
designed it so this was this was
submitted to us by Andrew Uyen so thank
you Andrew for submitting this design we
saw it and fell in love with it and this
is it calm down layer for my soup thank
you Andrew bitch it's a really cool
design yeah they are fully stocked all
the sides dirty oMG I want to thank
everybody also who obviously supports
the show in so many ways but I wanted to
thank everybody that ordered that
special edition sub Kane shirt those
started going out and then the the
mostly stories signed vinyl I went back
and signed a hundred more of them kind
of always went out as well I was so
surprised that people are ordering
vinyls I've never done it here's how
many they there was such a demand for it
that I got completely normal the first
special on vinyl it'll go out next month
awesome so I'll let you know when those
arrive but yeah there's making Fitness
everybody's been super supportive of our
store and it totally helps support this
show so thank you guys for doing that
Kevin Dulaney movie I'm down later for
moose soup um so I've found the moose
ouble do Facebook and I'm obsessed with
her and I I love her yeah I made her go
so she really sells Moo soup you know
that her thing here's a young
know how I'm going to - then for singing
in the party - yeah
[Music]
the musubi lady singing it's that voice
the voice civilly best part is actually
not seeing exactly he's hearing you
don't need to see her too I mean she
looks like how you imagine let's just
put it that way like she looks like that
person they don't know how I'm going to
Jackson quite a voice yeah Jackson
Jackson that by this is actually
somebody who I'm better suited to
impersonate than you are and it's a
woman
[Laughter]
my natural voice is closer Thank You
meryt in a fever hotter than a pepper
sprout what songs we've been talking
bout Jackson ever see so far away okay
you get um well how you get that voice
it starts deep because here's the thing
I have a pretty deep lady voice do you
think in 20 years I could get moose soup
lady voice um I don't know but I'd have
to start smoking again I don't know see
this is a shirt no it's somebody else's
yeah there's a lot of smoking involved
but I have to start smoking again
yeah here she is uh another good one
just
that's all I'm like oh man gee a canoe
out on the water and a small boat
[Music]
you know you know very glad to lend to a
horrible yeah that'd be yeah - I don't
work alright but you get the idea it
it's those type suit it's really her
it's all her it's all real yeah I'm a
soup
she sells no soup it's on she has a
garage sale right now she just loves
about a garage sale and she's like I
have mu soup bread dinner rolls I don't
know she pulls a phone number that's
crazy guys do not if you find it please
leave her alone
don't ya we don't want to interrupt this
she's in normal yeah and living a life
like let's not
master ozune mu soup but she's just
she's the best dude she Oh it says that
she's a professional cook oh wow yeah so
maybe she does make amazing new soup you
know that's cool well next time we're in
Alaska we should look her up she's
single she's got two there you go yeah
would you date the musu lady no I think
at this time in my life it's not
appropriate why I'm younger mm-hm
then you wait a little while how long is
it your wife after me I don't think what
is my wife after me like again so we
have this discussion who would marry
after me like your second wife
and oddly you're probably well I think I
think you should point out that at first
I suggested I was like oh I see it being
like a Latin guy and you're like yeah
and I go you're like a Brazilian or
something and you're like oh I could see
that so like that's what I set up to you
of like I could see that being your next
I would go Brazilian I love Portuguese
and I'll hear your like as neat and then
you go I go what about me and you said
and I go I see you with some nasty porno
chick like some girl who's like oh well
fucking piss on your balls and I put a
baseball bat in my ass like stuff like
that that's what I see you with cool
really cool i but hear me out
John because I see what somebody like
that because you know you did like the
good Family Guy thing on our our
marriage like we're doing the kid and
the dogs and like a normal existence and
who knows you might get so famous that
reality gets distorted like it does with
a lot of really famous guys you could be
that guy you know pushing your dick
through a wire fence to get it sucked
and and then you know what I mean the
legs so weird and then you could be like
I'm so sick of this boring wife and kid
lifestyle yeah I got to get with the
girl it pisses on my balls I'm just
going to why don't you piss on my ball
so you like no it is because you've been
repressing your savage desire like yes
Trish Bobby they have a pretty good sex
life like we have a pretty consistent
thing here and Bobby or Trisha Bobby but
I mean like I feel like you're going to
have some real deviant shit coming out
here bitch
later in life yeah OMG you told me as
long as it's later in life it's cool
though you're like oh that's are like 20
years you can buy Oh once our kid is in
college yeah you want a divorce find the
love or hate again you said we'd stay
together but I can do out yeah I want to
go don't get my balls you think that's
license to do that stuff as well when I
met I met now if we I like you so much
as a person if in 20 years we fucking
like the marriage is just not working
yeah but maybe we'll still live together
like the French do okay oh but we don't
have your paramour okay but I like you
that's the stuff I'm saying like I like
to stay married I like you too I don't
know why you think I'm going to go get
my balls pissed me yeah that's okay I
know you I just I feel like that's going
to be your next thing like my next thing
is getting my balls pissed on
[Music]
well we'll be joined by the great Yoshi
obayashi here in just a few minutes I
want me to take a quick break and we'll
be back with him oMG and we're back and
we're joined by one of the all-time
great guests my mom's house podcast is
Yoshi obayashi
[Music]
absolutely you're here Josi thanks for
it's always good to see you
last time we saw you ly think was at the
live show yeah yeah fine sperm buy in
California but I think the last time I
did a show at your place it's been a
couple years well you were an old
student like our old place yeah by the
beach area yeah yeah long time ago we've
had two Studios since right yeah yeah
one two and this is the third one so we
just yeah and actually if you want to
add up all the different rooms we've
done it in is that there's the first
room in Silver Lake yeah all that's
right oh geez man let's do that then
the beach yep room and then the beach
office because I went to he did that we
do then the rental house and and then
here so there's five columns I know
let's hope this one stays for a while oh
my god sports franchise find you guys
got a real on a real really fancy yeah
yeah it's a real place to do it and then
yeah it's a it's always good to see you
man it's good I'm glad you could come
here all right okay have to beat you I
know you've been you've been doing a lot
of things man you were you in Europe you
said right recently yeah but before your
fans are so I mean they're just so clay
love you thank your you're a homerun
with it when it comes to our fans in the
show they're very kind and even show up
in some shady dive bars and I couldn't
believe it really yeah they're always
coupling and no matter how how much of a
horrible things I've seen stage there
they're just so lovely and you're good
at you say some horrible horrible things
yes
I'm gonna do the last show this lady I
think the tail end of the show your fans
were there to tell them but she said I
left it every GOP day I even laugh at
your fisting jokes but when you make
jokes by aids my brother died 25 years
ago and she was very upset with me when
people are upset I let them say whatever
yeah you know they paid so and how does
it affect you when they spin there when
they are upset and does it does it
affect you in some way though I mean I
might believe and I do have feelings but
like I don't want to get into the detail
but there's not not once of ounce of
malice in that joke it was right and I
totally believe you
I'm trying to make people to be
sympathetic but how do you handle her
like when she says I'm very upset and
and she's done saying it do you say
something in response you know it's like
I lit her I don't interrupt
yeah I let her say it yeah because this
is not she was trying to get attention
did she was genuine her and she was
hearing me say horrible stuff she was
all the way with me for yeah the tail
end of it I literally call the way and
she got her stuff she got out as soon as
she closed the door I said but I have 20
more eight jokes for you and the people
laugh but situation like that you you
should let them say whatever I'm okay
with that yeah um and I think this is
something I face a lot in Sweden you
know I remember saying something about
wimp they literally they take jokes
literally they get upset without not
knowing the intention with that make
sense to you yeah but what I also tell
them like I don't have a problem you
speaking during the show and that's okay
with me
but when you do that you're basically
saying everyone in the room have no
rights to hear what I have to say
because we would jump to conclusion
about it yes oh but I think I don't
think this is just me there's a lot of
convenience of facing this like couple
of weeks ago when Bill Maher gun trouble
for that joke he's been very supportive
minorities you know I listen to that
joke he used and then where I don't
think it was malicious at all and people
are just overreacting
well it was pretty big reaction I think
you know people he bigger issues
institutionalized I can't even say the
racism and
young black kids getting shot and those
are the bigger issues not agree oh not a
joke yeah yeah I think I think he did do
that thing where it's like him saying
that joke if he were like hanging out
with like in a room yeah would be people
would laugh and have no like wit here's
a comics for sure but doing it on TV
it's like it's one of those things where
I think people interpret it as it's not
so much the joke yeah but they're going
youth you think you have a pass why do
you think you like that's what a lot of
people we're taking it right yeah like
why do you get to say that you know and
also people who are not fan of his and
don't watch his comedy when they see a
small clip on YouTube didn't they just
make all this assumption not knowing
believe me he has done a lot of good
things out there I'm a fan and
especially the drug policies you know he
sees those been finding the draw yeah
yeah yeah but we live in the people
people are going to attack you no matter
what absolutely now well and I think
people have always there's always been
these Aselton assholes people who are
offended at everything and it used to be
that you had to call the television
station and now you can just immediately
get outraged on Twitter you can reach
but you can tweet Bill Maher himself
right now he knows who's mad at him it's
the immediacy of communication to I
think I don't know
so anyway Yoshi mentioned that you're
doing some medical testing lately right
are you doing did you say that you're
saying something I finished one in three
months ago if I'm going to do another
one late next month it's going to be 36
days I have in quantum 36 days yeah this
one in a minute what are you doing I
don't know the drugs but like I always
saw only pant hinged on Monday pay so
they just said is it paying a fortune
for almost 13 grand I think that's
pretty good
oh I think the same how long is that
stay how much is to pay I'm very what
are you do you know what they're going
to be testing no but I don't really care
per se most of the only thing I care
about is if it's anything with brain
related like if you have a bipolar or
any of those kind of mental medications
I will not touch those but cancer
no Alzheimer's you've gone for all of it
yeah I've done it yeah scent album what
will I do to you in 36 hours
what will they do to you in 36 days this
is what typically actually happened
I'm not even concerned by taking the
medication so I'm always like everyone
is starving because they cut trying a
calorie like I got as low as 116 while
studies I brought by a game like 17
pounds but I already know once I go in
for 36 days I'm going to drop at least
20 to 25 so it's like a diet for you too
that's the biggest reason my brother
littlejoy yeah I don't know that's my
number one I need to lose weight but I'm
too lazy to lose weight I mean you did
an amazing job I mean a lot yeah I lost
I look great thanks buddy I mean lost 50
pounds I've kept it off I actually lost
a couple more pounds since the weigh-in
yeah no it's good because you know I
mean you have a lovely wife but most
importantly yeah you have a child you
know yeah yeah and some of my are I
don't want to mention names but some of
the comedian's friend of mine they're
over when I'm just worried about their
kids more now yeah Russell yeah oh sorry
what do we know so Peter said he will he
will want to do podcast yeah I am love
to him so Europe I saw was a but you
don't know you don't know what you're
sorry you don't know what you're getting
into for this next no when do you find
out what the drug is and can you pull
the plug on it like if they show up and
you show up in it something you don't
want to do can you sing now and leave oh
sure that's it so basically when you you
have a like I got it I just emailed them
like I'm running out of money so that's
when I usually mail them and then
they'll tell me these are the following
studies we have and then that I love
that one I just love the system for
you're like I'm running out of money
what what medical tests you have going
on there's like four or five different
facilities in Southern California huh
and this one this guy always email me
back right away because they're always
afraid even if they pass the screening
they go in after five six day they can't
do any but they just lose their mind
because you can't leave you know and
your
hungry your hands are shaking because no
coffee and caffeine do all the tests
dictate low calorie intake like no
matter what your no so these these
business okay so every pharmaceutical
companies make drugs to make trying to
make profit billions of dollars in
profit right but it said amiss but they
don't have a drug to be tested every day
so they have another another business
called CRO clinical research
organization all they do is take a
contact by pharmaceutical company and
say hey we have a X medication we like
to Testament people and we need forty
people between this age at this body
mass index and they can be a smoker so
they have all kinds of different
criteria for each medication based on
each pharmaceutical coming so yes
there's some studies we could drink
coffee great there's other studies where
you could do equally almost anything now
there's other studies come so strict you
know no sugar low calorie pain yeah so
those are the ones like so you want to
get forced to diet actually you want you
wanted that's that's one of the major
benefits and when people say like it's
dangerous but like man I feel so much
better when you lose weight I am good to
be skinny pills better so now I mean
here's a question because you've done so
many different jobs you've had all these
chemicals in you I mean at some point
don't you think the the body is pampered
like you mean like not a pure specimen
anymore that's a tabula rasa so to speak
you're you're kind of tainted good by
only feel like that yeah like you know I
had this conversation two years ago in
Vegas and this guy I don't remember his
name at the party and he was telling me
oh my god would never that that's your
stupid to do that that's too dangerous
and he was telling me while he was ready
to snort coke so everyone have a
different idea of what's dangerous so
you're right I mean I can't tell you if
I were to never go into this business
versus now I'm taking a two versions of
yoshi's which one would have been
healthy no I'm not saying that I'm just
saying that I wonder if your body is it
to be but you're handsome eh yeah like
because you've done so many of these
like at what point can you not do them
anymore because you've ingested so I see
my age restriction or our know just
chemical restriction like cuz you like
they or they go thanks guys
this has been tested on a hundred
medications therefore you know that's
like you can't do it interesting is like
too many miles I'm not saying I did it
so don't do it
yeah but many of these organizations
don't talk to each other oh I don't know
they don't know so what happened is
general rule is they wait until thirty
days before they contact you because it
takes about two to three weeks for their
whole medication to get out of your
system so to be safe on one month but
there's times if you're broke you finish
one study you drive across a town I'm
not saying I did it you could drive from
one study to another study and you
barely make it there and do another
screening and hop onto another studies
but there's this group of guys I only do
in southern Canada
there's group of guys it's like Fight
Club they go literally city to city next
day to stay you know do studies all over
the place
I'll see you guys like oh I remember you
2014 liver cancer study what's up and
then they call me yo4 Yoshi obayashi
I don't remember the guys name K M
whatever so yeah an issue of each other
but there's a circuit and you know all
the players a lot of them yeah I mean
it's almost like when will you go in if
you go in for this one the I I think
they're going to call me within the next
7 to 10 days for screening then after
they do their testing
well first they make you read the
documents telling you this page through
that right yeah I have to react well yes
only there's only one facility to test
you if you fail that test they know that
you didn't read it and they'll
disqualify although other place they
don't give you shit there's one
particular so shady even if you get
caught doing something wrong like get
out of the room talk to another person
we do the interview second time around
to pass it they would do stuff like that
I'm not gonna tell you which one because
I mean now when you were you were just
doing a European tour with Jim Norton
yeah I just happened to be there for
Oslo Freedom Forum for like okay then
right stuff you happen to be there I
happen to be there then his manager who
we're not going to talk about it but
contact you as well he asked me could
you help Jim steal tickets or you know
where it's a good place to visit I just
happened to be in the same week when he
was performing okay so by default under
hoping for him and I was it
okay I'm glad because there's a lot of
comedians that you guys are such an
open-minded people I know you don't have
a fear of going over seen during comedy
but there's a lot of funny people in
America during stand-up on one reason
that they don't like going overseas or
they have this irrational fear but I
don't know yeah they just don't go for
some reason humilated right or something
yeah and I'm glad Jim Durkin team did
extremely well and brain who is our tour
manager he was in charge of public
francisco fluffy and bill burr and he
told us basically jim sold about same
amount of tickets bill burr first year
he went to europe it was very successful
wonderful and jim it was good exposure
to see outside of this country such a
good comic though yeah very surprising
and he's a nice dude on top of it now
did you visit any ladies of the night
when you were touring you are so
perceptive when we when we were on again
when I went to Edward to do a show
afterwards Jim went to go and check it
out
jim has never been to those places and
he wouldn't do it because it's too low
class because he get the high end first
class you know I'm the southwest of
cooker you know take a bath with he's
like you know the sun's or whatever but
so we went to the one in Antwerp and
it's a midsize level one and it was
really good and what kind of prostitutes
there where are they from
mostly Eastern Europe but I tried what I
do know this last couple of years
because European economic crisis you
juice everyone to see like wow you're
German or you're Dutch and Greek and
Spanish Spanish many people and
that's probably doesn't help I mean
there's no there's their sphere in
Europe of all the changes not just
terrorism but job wise you know and I
don't think Jim got a girl but what I
was surprised too every window with
transsexual lady I mean they look so
good I can't even tell I have really man
Jim was 100 percent knew right away like
I don't know how he does I'm putting
knew that that was a female that she may
have you been with shemale is I forget
know nearly no one I can't afford it but
now that's not never been in my data at
a premium
they cost more yeah really yeah why why
wouldn't you think because I just don't
know I I don't know what they cost more
and again i'm sidered more exotic so
it's i think so Wow and why I mean it
seems like their prices are a lot higher
than other ones you know wow that's got
nothing like one stone they are those
cheaper they are the best of both worlds
the transsexual I imagine that's why
it's like a bonus feelin when did you do
that interview with London real London
real TV that was was that on this trip
wait I don't member this one I thought
because someone said that you did this
interview now you said it pass out
yes you pull the skin a lot of people
they never circumstances yes so does
skin so you should have skin and get the
oil in the hand and you wrap hand cold I
did you rub rub rub rub especially on
the kind of thickness rub them
sissy Tom right okay because you make
them strong and not sensitive
so that's world famous Tom boo right
remember Tom boo know what remember not
a this a Southern California there was a
of this Vietnamese guy selling real
estate scam and you'll is it and then
he's on the boat with all this white
women around him and bikinis and it was
like who's that guy with the big hair
the teaching people painting oh all
right it was that level of cult
following
and Tom boo oh I can't believe you know
keel in space VSM victory double-o Tom
blue I never heard it oh my god now he
said like a famous poker player and
anybody says guy oh yes is videos oh I
can't remember that guy yeah you're from
California right yeah I can't believe
you don't know him I mentioned about the
rest of y'all that's of all cheering
here the transactions are wrong so would
a check for $15,000 and remember this
I took the town blue profit seminar so
it works for me at any financially
secure ones you squint - you can do it -
I don't have the se habla stories
anymore you can give yourself the best
rate of your life come to my seminar
wrap you have the crab you check me he
does look like you're ever okay late
$33,000 well I can apply the time with
technique $3,000 on this house you can
do it to my seminar is a solution but
these are people work hard but I
underpaid using the tombow what maybe
$12,000 a lot of my student who are
average people a lot of money why not
you see what year was that that was like
84 yes did I remember Tom do now I can't
believe you didn't know Tom boo that's
you know you have hey Rob Rob you think
you come one one right side future
carbon monoxides all the time back good
to come down a lot okay how often am I
doing this you have to do every day and
do you can control every day what are
they talking about
well he's just talking about sharpening
the knife he calls it oh and it's like
master control of your orgasms you know
or yeah so he's when many decoration
pressure all exactly like I said I don't
have to be here
exercise exercise and for people have
prospect men soul enough a problem
this one is solve the problem and now
you do it until you feel okay this is
good here haeseong's where you can
without ejaculation right so you feel so
you see when you do when when you get it
it's very quick to two times again cream
is all guess I'm coming
we thank you or she care you know there
are in a variation Taichi yeah touch me
go yeah you mean you could do the 50 50
50 rubs no way no way right 5350 is
where you added up 350 strokes every day
so you can control it I mean Rocco can
do that the rest of us can well my salsa
Friday's the king
have you talked talked to Rocco lately
do you know him personally no last time
I heard from him is when Joyce of era
called me in Boston when I was doing
shows there and he was hanging out with
Rocco and say Runkle save I'm sad to
hear that you don't work an evil angel
and I hope you're doing well
so they're they're nice people yeah and
yeah such an animal
I can't I laugh thinking about like I
imagine over the years in my mind
conversations he has what his wife who's
like she's like when is enough of this
poor thing I knew it one of the times
beta B's how am I going to make my mommy
hey you know it's not even for me really
good idea I don't know it's kind of
enraptured buyers who have acting no I
do it for them I don't you know what's
interesting
he released a documentary within last
year to about his sex addiction problems
yeah I want to say we played the trailer
I'd love to fly where is that where can
we watch that I don't know I'm
fascinated by him you know actually at a
wrestle Peters taping a few years back I
had a rock cocaine backstage backstage a
conversation with Rocco and I am I don't
remember this
so you met Alice here
at The Wiltern now I think tom was
anyways and I met him and we had a
really good personal conversation he
told about the childhood stuff no I
swear to god he's super cool because he
knows I was Hungarian and his wife is
Hungarian loves Hungarian girls yeah Wow
anyways I really like him as a human but
you know what he could make yeah yeah
and he's such a funny guy did I tell you
that one time he was so disappointed
that that he was telling me that I don't
know these kids he was talking about his
like nephews and stuff like I don't know
what so what the fuck's wrong with these
kids none of them went in to get into
porn of his and all they ever talked
about video games he was complaining
about I do games social media and you
told me that yeah sometime today
but that passes through my head as such
a hilarious dialogue there's somebody's
like sign 16 now it is your turn to make
a partner yeah and the kids like I
wanted if I want to play Grand Theft
Auto and he's like no but 16 is part of
the time and the kid is like what I just
want to play video games dad and he's
like what is wrong with you boys I think
society nice I think I didn't I haven't
seen the documentary but if you're being
completely like being real about it yeah
when you're in that business so you have
a drug addiction whatever addiction is
because you have a something missing in
your lives and intimacy right because
yes it's interesting with porn you're
doing most intimate things but it has so
little intimacy in it you know oh yeah
and it's for people who are consuming it
with personal issues a lot of them you
know like if you're one of those people
to watch every once in a while
fine but if you always need it it's
because there's up there's something
wrong with you oh yeah absolutely
yeah I'm not attacking the business I'm
not on we never I think what you're
saying is intuitive it's like you're
spot on because drug addiction or
alcohol or corn oil in the interview
yeah that the interview about the
documentary I remember that we we read
it on the show that he had retired from
performing me and then he was you know
but that he was still going to hover
three times a day oh wow
- and his wife add some blow just go
back to shooting again this is crazy
again it's not like to orgasm there's
some some kind I'm sure there's some
kind of trauma that you learn to sex or
drugs or whatever to give you comfort
you know oh yeah oh yeah trauma that's
why I think one of the director johnny
dark oak is always like shot like I know
you guys get such a big fan look I think
you could look here oh this is going to
be in Italian with French oh Jesus
so it's not so it's called Raqqa that's
what I kept bag at all
I wish I can artistically 100 K can't
show that 1500 abogado Cola propia
anyway wolf I'm kinda sailors piped out
horses Kannada Padre Aquila D
proprietary um Tito love you Miko's
project ready
that man into YouTube why you
everybody's all over that go to work for
me what they say Krakow and kill you
yeah and why you come this is Shula
Frank good stuff
yikes wait so we would get back way back
but whatever but there was a funny scene
where one of the girls that my dad is a
big fan of yours really I think he start
fucking her and like okay and he's
fucking a doggystyle now look at the
cameras they hide your daddy and I keeps
walking in like that so he likes the yes
very large yeah wait so so did you see
any hookers and Antwerp you're saying
I'll find a new place I was really
shocked
Oh so please do tell okay this is
shocking to me so I I finished the show
work of a gym fantastic it was great the
audience are wonderful and talk about
your fans you got your fans listen to
the show because there's so much
intimacy and this bitch make people are
really happy like ice ain't Johnny Darko
one of the director he's a big fan of
yours and like he was really happy that
I'm on the show all the time so anyway
great job with that after after that
comedy tour I flew into Athens Greece
because one of my friend was working at
a refugee camp so they look at these
people just like a refugee no no no no
no no no it's funny you say that because
I do have some so there's a place called
City Plaza Hotel is abandoned in the
Pearl refugee group took it over I don't
know how many maybe 500 800 refugee
people living there my friend was
working there as a volunteer and when I
showed up he was known he timing was bad
so he could be there so I just kind of
walk through and check it out and Rob
Rob Rob yes yeah the city of the city
happened
they don't want to deal with the refugee
problem so I have a lot of refugees
already Albanians are there and Syrians
yeah okay
fucking gypsies now they're just hard to
check out and I'm a good know the newer
printer and they treat them real bad so
they don't acknowledge it
and the people who run it don't want to
bother the city are there because
they're so they're pretending it's not
happening so anyway I kind of went there
even though my friend wasn't there
check it out they're doing good job but
it just shows like even if I have a good
intention my mind go to the dark place
aside because I sold really good-looking
Syrian girls walking and what popped in
my head was I went to show give me
blowjob a hot dog right a hot dog eating
because I didn't do anything charm but
yes but those thoughts do enter my mind
I do not blame you for those those are
normal fun anytime I don't you just
don't do it don't do it yeah don't do it
you have those thoughts to about you
think she blow me for a hot dog I think
I think that on a regular basis I get
the groceries you're like I wonder if I
got her gross she give me a blowjob in
the parking lot all right anyways but
you didn't see any actual prostitute
paid for no but in Athens I didn't know
that prostitution is legal all right so
I was there for three days
so by like first night I was bored
because it's hot
and then I just said the internet search
did not find out that um instead of
red-light district it's called white
light district white light so it's
called white light district so
prostitution legal but you can't have a
pimp representing you but it's legal and
unemployment for young people between 18
through 30 is hovering almost 50% as
well Jesus yes terrible was great for
prostitution yes so is we should go
there so I've been added the one to piss
on my balls yes and put a baseball bat
in her ass for you like you like wow
that sounds like belladonna um it is
like belladonna that's exactly what I
was thinking of I like her she's great
I've met her before the most pro
portable pothead pristine is version
whoo
she thinks that that I'll be over the
family thing and be like I just want
some chick to piss on my balls
yeah well right wait is that something
you're really into no no no okay okay
she thinks it's a trip like that it's
more of a metaphor for like letting out
whatever is repressed because I'm a
family guy now
I just feel like you're going to get
also the same will get to you and the
banality of your everyday existence will
weigh on you and we were thank you
and then you'll you'll be like I just
want someone to pee on my balls but I
can't ask my wife doesn't she another I
we would yeah of course
wait what peeing our balls is cheating
but why why if you see someone's couch
and what why do you have some it's a
girl ah female do it whatever episode
you yeah that would be even more
upsetting I think really well because
it's both
Bopha sexist cheating it's like a super
human okay someone pee on my ball now
paid can I have someone pee on my vagina
yeah you went my mouth no it's one eyed
peas on my taint if that's what you like
okay I figured like a bet of that all I
need to do and you're probably and
you're happy and every like good good
with that piece go get that pee you want
on your taint event stop you know in
Athens I was there 10 15 years ago now
and the dudes were holding hands they
still do that I didn't see that
middle-eastern mother oh that's what
maybe that wasn't yeah maybe I saw those
dudes and they carry their beads around
they had hand holding
yeah they have a very weird notion of a
personal space but it but what men would
men but they don't like when the women
with a man unless they're married or
something yes the Muslim well man
but now hooker is an Antwerp you're
saying oh no I got to yeah well let's
talk about those nobody things is
amazing because while I districts so
basically you go to this certain Street
to do it they're legal you walk down the
street even during the daytime they have
this really tiny bright white light that
means there's a prostitute there and the
doors are wrapped with this
cloth so when you close that though it
doesn't slam the door so you go in if
it's all if you go in it looks like a
disco room with this shiny things are
going in a circle like wow this is weird
you sit down and usually there's another
guy sitting so you're sitting here
waiting for long times and the confident
happens yeah that's like like what will
happen what does it happen what happened
this is so such a strange then then
they've literally call their mamasan so
she'll they're all women walking okay
and she'll speak if she see a foreigner
then she'll speak in Greek and English
she said normal sex only I don't know
what that means and normal sex 10 year
olds like I have to find what 10 euros
if you don't know that is a 10 year old
oh no girls cocaine here oh yeah no no
nobody here is coming noon
that's what how much is that now 11
dollars and 50 $10.50
that's how bad the euro is again so wait
a minute how did you listen back him
how'd you end up at this place like how
do you how does how do you end up there
they said that uh I don't remember the
industry they say like this case with a
couple Street today they're legal to go
okay so I walk down the street but
there's no sign thing hookers right even
if even if they did dead it's in Greeks
I can't read that so I start walking
like after why you starting only guys in
the neighborhood yeah they went back and
forth of these rooms like oh so I know
this pattern like white lights metal
doors with cloth so when you slam it
doesn't make a lot of sound so I open
the door I go in and it's like a disco
roof right so when then she said where
after she said 10 euros normal sex then
what then a girl walks in across the
room from one door to another and you
see them for a second so you get to like
their eyes all the good yeah and the
first point I went there I mean she must
been 60 years old and oh like what the
fuck I'm not doing this so like as I'm
leaving she was assistant to give me a
kiss like being friendly like I wanna be
I don't wanna be rude but she was so
friendly but like you know she I was
just making funny face and she came and
just kiss me in the lip like oh my god
talking about that how we when strangers
want to kiss you on the mouth like they
sometimes even like a romantic thing
some people do like she wasn't being
nasty but she was behind a knot but I
don't want to hurt her family because
she's probably what doesn't make unless
you're into like older overweight
without your only option no no no no I
left there but I was like oh man this is
I don't know if I want to do this but
there's so many rooms that so many
buildings I just talked to everyone then
eventually I went to one door and she
was pretty it's like okay I still bet
it's a scam because okay ten-year-olds
but once you go in she gonna say ok you
if you want this now the five if you
want this 20 that's what I thought and
then so if the guy doesn't like the girl
they leave and they go to another
building so like okay I like that one so
like oh I'll pay for this one and I give
the old lady ten euros and then she
grabbed me took me to this room and it's
like a room with very basic furnitures
with bed so you're just sitting and
every once in a while you hear
high-heeled walking by alright so she's
going back and forth and I guess every
building with one door one girl only
so just way on Chiltern oh man so you
just wait and I think I went like half
an hour for this one and she came in and
the describer
she is Eastern European but I think it
she was little darker so I think she's
probably like Bulgarian or something one
of those or Macedonia or something like
that and she didn't speak whole out of
English but she was she relatively like
I don't know late 20s or 30 just make
light English when you just making sweet
love all right we love to get ten
minutes normal sex like oh like ticket
like you have to finish with everything
by 10 minutes you know but if she says
that like that's what she leads yeah
because if it's Greek I'm sure she learn
to speak to them in Greek or whatever
but yeah I was shot it's only ten years
old I asked and I could not believe and
if you look you could find gem and yeah
there's other ones that after a while
you see a really pretty
once but they all have rules like no
like II know this and Dad I eat the ass
and pussy all the time I got nothing so
did you get to do that so I know some of
the girls won't let you do it
really yeah but how could you complaint
10 euros oh yeah true I mean 10 G once
you get maybe a couple dances you're
actually having a blowjob and a couple
of positions inside with ten minutes
good for you those enough I mean it's
just ten you can't complain so you just
got to finish it
yeah you know what if you just play I
know I just like doing it just like just
like you're in stand-up you know you
know when the right lights you have two
minutes ago yeah yeah now if you paid
her 20 euro cuz you double your time or
is that not even an option
mm-hmm you could pay somebody for like
64 whole hour if you wanted to yeah well
next time I mean what did I bring your
cash you know but there's other streets
it's like girls are twenty year olds
there's other shit this studio and like
Leon fucking for ten ten bucks and then
did you have to wear a condom with that
math yeah okay
I don't know I mean here's the thing
anything is negotiable if you say you
want to pay them 100 for no condoms I
mean do you will find a girl who will do
it that is a crazy gamble or not a good
idea but it's $100 a night I mean or the
good to get no condom blowjobs or boy
you know yeah I mean depends but
everything's negotiable you know and but
a lot of the girls so tell me there's
guys that don't want to have sex and
just want to spend with the time with a
girl those are the guys I would take if
I were a prostitute like just give me ur
lonely yeah or not going or some other
gruesome like all she had to do is watch
him eat for like an hour
eating yeah what about farting have you
encountered anybody that just wants a
girl to fart oh yeah let's talk about it
where did where did you encounter that I
mean I I mean when I get to know that
some of the girls still tell me weird
stuff like or they think another big
things like they like girls sitting on
cake and shit like that
take farts are just sitting on just
getting on food you know Tom and I have
started a website called fart Mistress
where we would like yes
yes Israel we're not sure how we're
going to get a performance apart this
has happened but we've come across these
part videos where it's just girls
farting and there's nothing sexual
happening like do you know girls that do
fart videos like they just fart for $100
sure I mean if you paid him they would
do it right I don't know any like you're
asking me like certain girls are for
prolapse and certain girls are doing for
a strip strip attack strap-on attack I
mean there's some girls a name attached
to certain fetish but I don't know any
famous girl in trial he's into
everything I just Diane was dropped in
that in masturbating when his penis was
dropped and he slaps it on this valley
they call that masturbation force aliens
and so I just I one thing led to another
and I couldn't resist so I bent down and
started sucking on him that's raw horse
oh I hate this documentary then he tried
climbing on top of me so the next thing
I know my pants are down and I'm bending
over for him and I'm like excuse me I
can't resist a guy the guy that work for
Boeing got killed and yeah in his day
that's right that was that documentary
was about that yeah good I can't resist
mmm yeah you shouldn't talk with animals
they don't can't give consent I don't
think that's fair yeah they can't say
anything we haven't discussed this yet
our Kelly posted he's in some shit now
yeah he's always in shit yeah he did you
know it's he's somebody who has really
been able to navigate the horrible press
probably better yeah then most I mean I
remember that either the Chicago Tribune
or sun-times did this expose a while ago
yeah really laying out all the
complaints that were in a Chicago
courthouse basically every filing that
had ever been made as a complaint on him
and it was like they're like look this
is the record-setting number that then
that that didn't get any attention
everybody always knew about that video
with the pissing and
and what don't you think it has a lot
also to do with the victims there are
victims but they're black women black
women who are usually and they're young
teens
yeah we're not like talking about if you
know if the narrative was if it was a
young white girl I think I think
reaction we quite different no I think
you're right that's right right but the
Danish she never pretend like it was a
wholesome family guy either no well here
this is not fucking talented I don't
like what he did I know that he it's
unbelievable does this learn now they're
saying that he's got women holed up in
different houses and asses on takes away
their phones and just basically keeps
them yeah and and tells them when to eat
when to bathe when you know it's like
it's pretty nuts this is the latest
activate this is separate from that but
this is and I would drink from her
lipstick part because in a son by the
way I had a serious serious crush on my
mom she could sing but office okay so
here crunch and I just looked up and
down to her I looked around I look
everything about my mother you know I
love her and I even asked her to marry
me one thing I was like man she said no
but you know what I understood I
understood but don't you think he's
being very honest about it I think it's
like the game it is just like the gays
cuz remember I think last time I told
you at the live she'll ask them will you
ever date your mom yeah yeah that when I
did your live she'll you know porn
having credibility to particulars can be
next president but Trump I think I kind
of mind him being so honest about you
know the new trend is tableaux relations
or incest porn or those arts really
popular right now and you're saying that
so I think that I mean the way he was
talking about his daughter yeah like if
she wasn't my daughter would date her
you know but and I even asked her to
marry me
Astin will you ever date your mom the
incest thing on the show yeah really lot
another level
but he really was I mean I understand
you're saying it is kind of
creepy the way that Trump talks about it
but it is I guess honest to kits on both
sexes go through that in the Freud even
talked about that right yeah Oedipus
complex but also girls for their father
is just when you restore an age you just
outgrow that but yeah some people
obviously don't you know and I think
Levi Strauss the philosopher or that
whole notion of taboos started with the
whole idea of taboo and not have sex
with family related you know cuz uh you
reckons before then it wasn't I guess a
big deal I mean people marriage or
cousins all the time like royal family
it's all I'm Colchester still really
marry their cousins yeah yes yeah SD are
you know I mean there are four to five
removed or something but there
nevertheless family and I remember
reading this article one time in England
when I was visiting there was a nuclear
plant or something near one of the
cities in England and they were having
all kinds of a medical and biological
problem with like they thought it was
some kind of radiation leak or something
but when they did a little remember
research they find out it was like
incest
you know just family members having sex
with each other it wasn't a bigger
implant so it happened more often than
you think it does and look at Utah there
is renegade Mormons the Mormon Church
does not condone it but there are people
still multiple wives and you know
there's all these weird things that
happening yeah I don't get it I mean
like as a parent now like that's the
second last thing I can even fathom it's
like it's just not on the table looking
for a lot of health problems with that
health problems with the with the
genetic proud you know with yes actually
I heard the I heard cousins are okay I
hadn't professor in college what did I
did I had a professor in college say
that my husband fucking is not a it's
not the genetic mutations it's it's
immediate like when you're going father
daughters and I problems with cuz with
cousins I can definitely well definitely
well have to see you look at look at the
studies there's no studies out there
yeah about the cultures that have the
most
cousin mayor
and reproduction and is just rampant
health problems and just like dogs
it's just same things across creating
greening and breeding and yeah and I
think was it Germany there was a case
where these fraternal brothers sisters
separated they didn't even know other
existed and how much some really weird
coincidence against they met never knew
they were related and they start having
relation hang on and you know and yeah
what are you doing that situation I mean
it's a sexy story but it's a very sexy
story I'd go retarded you go retarded at
that point oh I'd rather be retarded
than that is my brother Yoshi would you
rather how about this so sorry this is a
regard to the last podcast okay female
hey Hitler during the opening episode of
405 you guys disgust the pleasure of
orgasmic birth as a man I have no idea
what childbirth feels like we're willing
to take these woman's word for how great
childbirth feels Christina's tried to
shoot down the idea but I feel like it's
more likely that if something is wrong
with her Jenny ladies are all lying
maybe and our horrible personality is a
hindrance to the pleasure or possibly it
was her lack of hydration that led to
the painful experience love the palm Kat
Kang burnt is fat Nate thanks Nate
so well why don't you squeeze a person
out of your dick hole and we'll talk
about it yeah I mean it was pure pain
right yeah dude there's a listen these
fucking dirty hippies are trying to say
that a woman can have an orgasm during
childbirth you know I have yet to meet a
woman that that's really happened to I
guess in theory it's possible but it
ain't fucking probable I mean it is
excruciatingly painful and I had a
fucking epidural and I could still feel
it so now nothing sexy hmm
somebody emailed about male to female
pilots hey champs I heard you guys
speculating on the female pilot
situation because we talked about a
flight I was on female was yes they said
my spouse please use pronouns Pater Tim
that and I was informed take a seize at
leas hang a couple applications each
week for a new pilot's license due to a
gender change oh shit and considering
tey is one of four people that handle
these there has to be a pretty
substantial amount of pilots that have
changed their gender oh wow just thought
you might like some verification on that
point I'm just great week mommy your
newest coolest fan
Levi well you know by the way when you
sit at first male to female puttan
whatever I thought there was some kind
of new sexual positions I was confused
for Manta good yeah I know I don't know
well who knows this says that Garth
necked up Ireland oh yeah yeah this
person wrote hey jeans I love the
wheeler Walker jr. podcast the live
songs were great idea your conversation
about Garth being a moron
I wanted to draw attention what happened
a while back when G tried to play
Ireland's largest sports stadium Croke
Park well I want to let you know that
Brooks is huge in Ireland especially
with mums and rural Fork rural folk
excuse me the announcement of the gig
was a big deal he had not played here
for 17 years Wow
personally I think his music is utter
tripe and maybe slightly good if you're
really hammered at a wedding the
promoters and gar steam books five
consecutive nights in the stadium
something which has never happened
before tickets for release and sold out
immediately Wow
400,000 of them oh my god
the stadium is anna densely populated
residential area and concerts often
causing major disruption for this reason
there is a rule no more than three
concerts can happen in a row and one
week within the stadium when this was
announced by the council government
garth responds by pulling all the show
senate dating it's all or none it
basically caused a national emergency oh
shit the Irish Prime Minister tee shot
ended up having to make a statement in
Parliament about the whole fiasco it was
all anyone talked about he acted like a
total total spoiled
that everyone here was appalled by him I
live in Belfast I knew about ten people
who were devastated
here is a BBC news article about the
whole thing love all the way from
Belfast Ireland allowed Kiva O'Connell
way so sorry you did it fuckin a man but
they did cancel mm-hmm he did counsel
his elder he did he cancel cuz he said
it's all the shows are done and I guess
that is a good position to have as a
proposed if you're travelling abroad I
think it's well and for the sake of the
fans you can't who are you going to
decide who gets to see the show how are
you get inside you know which may I
really like that and which which nights
are people going to get screwed on
that's not cool how would he do that
I guess right like how would he choose
that's what I'm saying we probably it's
actually smart but that's crazy they
wouldn't let him I know everything was
cool stuff slick stuff neat stuff cars
Brooke
did you did you did you know that the
country music was so big and in northern
I would never have guessed I never would
have guessed
honestly this is how detached I would
have never guessed that he is of this
level of popular everywhere now I mean I
knew he was a star sure I didn't have
any doubt about that but like when I was
in Edmonton I was in Edmonton earlier
this year and he was there he did nine
arena shows bananas David like in a row
in a row where the Oilers play they put
a banner like when they put championship
banners yeah of Garth up there at the
end of the ninth show they're like this
is what an impact you just had here I
mean you know it we're talking he goes
somewhere and does hundreds of thousands
surrogates I had no idea he was that big
of a star you know I just knew he was a
you know a big deal but not like that I
mean I always say white people have
feelings too and white people do what
people do and one thing we learned from
Trump winning that there's been a group
of people they've been neglected and
maybe I don't know I don't know he's
music but maybe he sings songs about
people in the disparate situation that
except he give them comfort and he
really connects with that yeah I don't
attack hip hop a country I just I don't
know music you know but if he's doing
that and obviously he is
good for him and yeah but that's just
him well Canada it's not that surprising
it is still North America you know but
well yes oh yeah yeah that he sold out
that Stadium like they couldn't keep the
tickets that's crazy man
I mean he's a very principled person
because 400 tell me how much is I mean I
love you I war yeah yeah I didn't even
know you like Chinese me oh yeah that's
a lot he doesn't need money no but he's
going to take that money course yeah
he's got a feed Trish bigger every year
old man I like how that you guys like I
love it I say it to get your eyes to go
wide now that you guys are two are
talking about blind people I got a short
and simple question yeah do twin
brothers have the same dick size I'm
sure they know but I don't I don't have
a twin brother Frank thank a life
mysteries Yoshi we had that's a great
question a great detective
[Music]
I don't know we should call a urologist
who could validate or just win I 20 need
someone with an exact twin well he
didn't say I did all I'm assuming not
return was identical yeah I said no I'm
saying he didn't specify whether as
identical or fraternal in because
there's obviously you can be I had no
reason to say this but you I would
imagine if you are identical you're
identical like everything would you
how about Inc so America is I think
that's what he's he's asked but I'm
assuming that the dick is the same size
I'm a Stan Lee who can recall but we
have to find we know people that are
twins isn't Ryan
Ryan's a tickler yeah he's a twin is he
an identical or fraternal and then thank
you but then maybe the question let me
just see if I can it's interesting I
want to thing to say about that one I
don't know what study it was but each
succeeding son you have the percentage
of that kid being gay get higher really
yeah and then another one was my friend
Oggy oldest who wrote a book called
billion megatons of Professor Harbor
he said that gay men in general have a
bigger penis than heterosexual men by
quarter to a half inches I don't know
where the three companies a scientist
but yeah is there a reason for it do we
know why or a theory maybe be warming
most heterosexual don't people mental in
a minute but gay men are more sexually
aggressive oh yeah it's like a lot more
probably than yeah straight guys that's
why when they think their system which
is weird
their appetites way stronger didn't oh
and they fucked like crazy and it's so
readily now we also had debates about
blind people how do blind people know
when they're done wiping oh make a shit
right over the line person know when
they're done especially black blind
person because the the the how would you
know when when when does it begin at end
I mean he thought he did blinds I can
already blind so yeah but they have a
partner right but that's just because
they're blind doesn't mean to give them
a blind partner either right right no
not so your your theory is that they
can't
I mean they call the partner in and go
hey tell me tell me when this paper is
white again is that what you think yeah
or how does a very successful rich in
power for blind people know with their
daily good looking people because they
must have a system I should go look at
how would you know now you feel they can
feel your face they touch your face and
your features and see if they're
symmetrical I but if you never seen the
face before how do you know what's a
good look you know you tell my symmetry
I'm guessing okay dad and guessing you
can tell by features at the nose is like
a cute button nose or is it you know
wonky or whatever I don't know this is a
going to Christina arena but you know
that thing in Plato's Republic that all
the real object is setting and there's a
fire so the plug re of the cave Yoshi
yeah so that they're seeing a shadow of
something that is no real but them it's
real right correct until they go to a
light of day do you think the blind
people they have in their head
what's pretty face even though they've
never seen a pretty face ever before yes
you did
okay they have an ideal that's different
than maybe yours or mine maybe I don't
know
they have different I'm having so that's
never seen a face has an idea of a
pretty face yes yeah I think so too sure
because there are other senses are
heightened children we've had blind
people right and it wouldn't much it
wouldn't it wouldn't be maybe the same
ideal a societal ideal but it would be
an ideal in their mind or so we've had
blind people write in and they say that
the people know how to finish wiping
based on touch okay this your your
sensitivity to touch is heightened yeah
and you can you know heal the resistor
halo haters fuck because she has no
senses at all she's she was fuck they
taught her a good baseline of stuff
though i I think that one of the things
you would probably do if you were blind
would say you would ask a who's a whose
objectives considered very beautiful and
you'd learn with that angle then you'd
be like this is beautiful this is
beautiful
okay so because that would your sense of
touch would be heightened and you'd have
a memory of that you know that this is
what the burn victims are ugly because
anytime they have a beef jerky face
right so a beef jerky
yeah maybe no right everybody the idea
of what's beautiful is different I don't
know cyclamen I never respond
he hasn't supposed to come on here to
talk about the Hillary Clinton thing
that he didn't know anybody about and
then he he by ordered with her once I
started to drop another book I had but
there was a book called survival of a
beauty beautiful professor named Nancy
egged off wrote a book but she said
there is definitely certain mathematical
ratio of somebody being absolute aful
yeah there's clarity propulsion and I
know sometimes people say you shouldn't
judge people by the book or whatever but
if you're living in third world
countries it's important that you judge
people by their face because you don't
know if they have leprosy you know these
are a lot of practical things it's just
men we always do this we've judged women
by the visual cues yes women more
psychological cues absolutely you know
I'm looking for red flags you said that
you had red flags immediately when we
were dating immediately there was a joke
sir no no what is the what I want to
hear this I want to know imma know what
it what was the problem
Tom's red flags okay number one very
antisocial I invited him to a party this
is like right when we were kind of
starting to date I go come to this party
with all our friends are going to be
there he doesn't show up and then I see
him around I'm like hey why didn't you
go to that party because III fell asleep
so that was kind of weird that like I'm
shocked coach Tom always seemed very
social to me really oh they go and then
when we send Damon okay we were you know
it was a kissy-face time we're so in
love and he was like I like you so much
I just want to stab your eyes until they
bleed I want to punch you I want to I
want to just kill you like he kept
talking about wanting to murder me and
stuff I would say I think I want to put
your head through that dresser yeah but
I mean it was I said it like in a jokey
yeah Emma stole flag you know I just I
turned you to do I turned a red flag
into a pink flag because I was like well
I could be a sense of humor thing yeah
we're both comics so I was a tad humor
thing yeah but there's still some shit
under it and you know should have
examined what changed obviously
everything worked out well 12 years
later and
were normally you know but what changed
I just got to know him better I guess
yeah any other for some other flags made
me to this day like what talk to
yourself a lot like I look you know I do
I look over and he's literally going
like like freaking out to himself and
I'm like we talk soon he's like also and
so I'm having a thing I do that a lot I
do that a lot but I don't think that's
that big of a red line no I don't my dad
doesn't do so I've seen him do it so
many times and it does make me either
amuses me or I'm like fuck is wrong with
you so I can only imagine
so because gosh we don't care if you
have a career or good credit we just
look at your face the proportion of your
body your breasts you know as indeed but
there's a genetic reason for that but
women look at guys and say is he strong
and enough to be attacked my offspring
or not you have a social status is he
kind you know did you know these these
things really matter so guys just need a
nice pair of tits and that's it
yeah yeah it is true but there's a
reason that the fat surrounding breast
enhance is what necessary to keep a baby
very healthy so luckily for me she's got
a couple of stage rubriz on it they're
so big and droopy now they're not oh my
god they're destroyed please destroyed
alright um what else is there anything
what do you got coming up
yeah Yosh what you got um well I've also
been to Canada by the way I was banned
for 12 years 12 years I think I did the
van is usually 7 and 10 10 years but I
was just afraid to go but I went up
there for how the they take care of
addicts in Vancouver so I had to go
after working with the Russell Peters in
Portland so enough it was so
embarrassing because when you go up in
the bus they can't continue to travel
it's trouble to Vancouver and unless
everybody get on or you have to tell
them this person gonna get back on and
go to Canada so I was the last one to
get in I had to talk to three officers
you know I have to explain the whole
fiasco what happened but I went up there
what was the initial band for like a
fight or alcohol I was opening for
also Peters but I had a bag of porn
which is fun that's legal what coming
trouble was around at that time Michael
Jackson got in trouble for second
accusation molestation so in my notebook
I wrote Michael Jackson's favorite child
porn titles and so they found a bag of
porn which I'll point out is data was
just aa photographer said you know
kindergarten cock spongebob no pants
Carolyn's in Seattle
honey I spot the kids when you had a
brother game are here are greater job
these are great comedians but how how
did that turn into a band well they took
me to this room and when every one of
those DP and DVDs and I have to stand in
there for three hours watching porn with
these three Canadian officers because
they were making sure there's no kid in
there then but they have to get me for
something and you know even if somebody
here I was falsely accused of chopped or
my life is over
yeah so they say I think that's fine oh
so over yeah so I don't know why that's
so funny it wasn't funny at all it
wasn't funny mother happened but um or
you could just admit you're working for
this guy with a work visa that I agree
with that I don't care about not going
to Canada 10 years I'd rather take that
but what was so funny not funny at the
time but as he's typing mind problems
because you said if you go we could make
you see a judge about your child porn
even though they can there's no yeah
there's a job for and in Russell Peter
called me and say hey in the shorts
combate start an hour where are you and
I told them situation he goes well you
tell them motherfuckers go fuck them to
vote the guy heard him say that and I
saw him like he paused and like believe
whatever he's typing and then we typed
something over that
so Russell think it's funny but it
wasn't just terrifying you know and they
were just going after Pete and then they
thing back then let me do the show
because there's no fly back that night
so but they say first day in the morning
I believe so I did a show I didn't want
you on Eminem have to fly back so I went
up there for I'm okay Canadian Center
amazing job in Vancouver saving people
because they have the only one only
place in East Hastings
Vanda Vancouver
network of drug users reunion or
something they're kind enough to invite
me to up there and I saw about 80 people
in check heroin cowboy but they're
saving people's life because they're now
overdosing they have a community to help
people with the spread of HCD and the
number of overdose dropped crime drop
and it's working and we were trying to
pass a similar measure in Seattle but
impasse and we lost bunch of dear
friends and acquaintances in comedy
because of the addiction no I am and the
policy that we have is terrible in it so
are you going to have any upcoming shows
oh yeah ugh August 10th
laughs unlimited in Sacramento a p.m.
it's the first illegal comedy show
illegal comedy calm and I'm selling
magazines after the show which is
magazine you guys he gave us some August
10th yeah and it's a great weekend
because August 11 to 12 you are doing
showing Sacramento punchlines right it's
going to be a fun weekend so we're going
to show video from the magazine telling
exactly what I'm doing I need to sell
tickets because I'm already - 600 it's
literally blood money I'm paying so if
no one should stop I'm fuck where's it
where's that word laughs unlimited Oh at
last limit okay a p.m. August 10th and
November 11th in Phoenix Glendale
Arizona at the club off-the-cuff we're
doing another illegal comedy so I'm
basically just break even kill people
that we want to help people to addict
drug problems and alright man I'm trying
to go into Canada to do a big show
hopefully maybe even have a Russell
Peters hosting there but we lost 67
almost 70,000 Americans last year and
then a year before that
35,000 so that is a massive dramatic
chat and we're losing these are not bad
people I just want people know these are
your brothers sister uncle aunt or even
grandparents and our policies are
hurting people and speech guided so I'm
going to hopefully say people's lines
that's a very powerful message man I'm
glad you're doing that and your fans are
wonderful there's just a really nice
beat hit about pit up Yoshi on Twitter
you're at
Yoshio Viacom in illegal comedy calm and
laughs unlimited August and all right
Jeanne anything else no thanks for
coming here Yoshi we always love having
you and your fans are just wonderful I
mean I can't believe these couples
listen to my horrible jokes and event
very sweet thank you you're the best
all right guys we'll see you next time
thanks for listening come see Tom yeah
come hug me I'll be there things are
keeping thousands of thousands of
thousands thousands of thousands of
thousands thousands of swing down ginger
wanna fuck with my life we're gonna have
a career ambition yes ten hours on
Tuesday oh oh
Alabama day because I'm a crazy as
videos don't care about nothing about
her fucking neck so what a dope among
those our business okay
the second big reason in a life
accidentally stick your dick in rotation
around horses like you're taking about
also take you tomorrow alders take
you're taking a ball off you take you
tomorrow and go take your balls and
it'll take you tomorrow more hauls I'll
show you something good speakers down
here some people mixed I'll show you
something
speakers down here something I can't
stand with so my comment under one of my
video this is high no whooping I've left